[Música]
pasamos ahora a la información económica
me acompaña en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de esa decisión de rusia de
nuevamente reducir el flujo de gas
natural hacia europa diciendo en esta
oportunidad que tiene problemas técnicos
que es lo que pasa ha sido bueno moscú a
12 de estas fallas técnicas por el nuevo
corte pero accidente dice que rusia usa
el gas como una arma política lo cierto
es que rusia lleva meses reduciendo el
flujo de gas hacia europa ahora alemania
asegura que no existen razones técnicas
para una reducción de los envíos según
gazprom que es esta empresa semiestatal
rusa la nueva reducción es por el estado
técnico de una turbina tras cumplirse el
plazo para una nueva reparación según lo
estipulado por esta norma técnica rusia
actualmente suministra sólo el 40 por
ciento de los flujos habituales de gas
debido a que espera la devolución de una
de estas turbinas jaimes que estuvo
bloqueada en canadá debido a las
sanciones internacionales que ha puesto
occidente por su invasión en ucrania
pero desde este miércoles el flujo
caería a un 20 por ciento
es un nuevo golpe para los tensos
mercados energéticos cuyos precios
aumentaron un 10% tras conocerse de esta
nueva reducción todo sucede cuando la
unión europea busca llenar sus reservas
de gas para el invierno estas reservas
actualmente está en el 60% y la meta es
para el 1 de noviembre que alcancen el
80 por ciento sigue entonces la
incertidumbre energética en europa y en
eeuu todavía no saben y hay un debate
sobre la posible recesión económica van
a entrar o no van a entrar en recesión
es la pregunta que todo mundo se hace
este domingo la secretaria del tesoro
dijo que la contratación es una prueba
de que su país aún no está en recesión
durante una entrevista con la en bici en
la semana donde los informes económicos
serán seguidos por los inversionistas
janet yellen intentó dar esperanzas
sobre los temores de recesión esta
semana la reserva federal de eeuu
anunciará una nueva subida de los tipos
de interés pero el jueves el
departamento de comercio va a presentar
su primera esta estimación de la
producción de la economía en el
trimestre abril-junio
recordemos qué
el trimestre anterior fue negativo
algunos economistas pronostican que
podría mostrar una contracción también
por segundo trimestre consecutivo
se considera una recesión técnica con
dos cifras en negativa de forma
consecutiva pero yellen afirma que la
economía aún es saludable el gasto de
los consumidores está creciendo las
finanzas de los estadounidenses según
medias son sólidas y la economía agregó
más de 400 mil empleos al año este mes
hablemos ahora de las aerolíneas
europeas que están enfrentando huelgas
de su personal en tierra el grupo de las
aerolíneas de lufthansa calificó de
inadmisible la huelga convocada por el
sindicato de servicios verde la
aerolínea ofrece un aumento de 150 euros
mensuales para todos los empleados a
partir del primero de julio y otro
aumento de 100 euros mensuales a partir
del 1 de enero de 2023 pero el sindicato
reclama una subida salarial del 9.5 por
ciento y por lo menos de 350 euros
mensuales
la huelga se afectaría en esta semana
varios aeropuertos de alemania y la
próxima ronda de negociaciones entre la
aerolínea y el sindicato se va a llevar
a cabo el 3 y el 4 de agosto y en plena
época de vacaciones jorge hablemos de
zimbabwe porque tratando de mitigar la
inflación lanzaron al mercado monedas de
oro en ese país africano bueno según
según la idea del gobierno es que la
población
puedan adquirirlas como reservas de
valor la inusual medida fue anunciada
por el banco de la reserva de zimbabwe
para impulsar la confianza en la moneda
local esa confianza en la moneda de
zimbabwe es tan baja que muchos
minoristas inclusive ya no la aceptan en
cambio las personas prefieren luchar en
el mercado ilegal por los escasos
dólares estadounidenses para mantenerlos
en casa como ahorros o para usarlo en
las transacciones diarias a nivel
internacional las monedas de oro se
utilizan en países como china sudáfrica
y australia para protegerse de la
inflación y como una oportunidad de
inversión aunque no se utilizan tanto
como una divisa como espera hacerlo
simbad vamos a ver cómo les resulta ese
experimento ya veremos cómo les resulta
la idea hablemos de la agencia moody's
que pronostica una caída del pib
mexicano si hay una recesión en eeuu que
no sabemos todavía bueno y la
contracción sería del 1 7% del producto
interno bruto para el año 2023 si se
materializa esa recesión en estados
unidos en su simulador la próxima
realización global la agencia señaló que
una combinación de eventos desfavorables
ocasionaría esta recesión en méxico a
mediados del próximo año aunque prevé
una vez el producto interno bruto
mexicano del 18 por ciento para este año
la proyección indica que la contracción
económica se extiende desde el segundo
trimestre hasta el cuarto del 2023
cuando la economía tocaría a fondo según
esta agencia los principales riesgos
para méxico es la persistencia de
choques de oferta en la economía global
y estos precios también en las materias
primas indicadores empezamos en un world
free eeuu las acciones estadounidenses
oscilaron y terminaron casi sin cambio
ya que los inversores se preparan para
la esperada subida de los tipos de
interés en la reunión de la reserva
federal esta semana en europa la bolsa
de milán arrancó con una buena sesión en
positivo pese el anuncio de gazprom de
volver a bajar el flujo de gas en el
nuestro mundo para europa y en américa
latina la bolsa mexicana de valores
retrocedió un 0,13 por ciento en su
principal indicador reflejando cautela y
baja liquidez del mercado financiero
muchas gracias jorge esto por el momento
aquí en la economía a continuación el
debate en directo américa
[Música]